a Twitter war breaking out between two
prominent voices on the left and the
right it all started with Rosie
O'Donnell's suggestion that she would
bribe lawmakers to vote against the tax
bill Ben Shapiro wasn't having it saying
that's a violation of federal law from
there things got increasingly well
personal with though Donald telling
Shapiro to do things that we can't say
here on television prompting Shapiro to
send out this tweet today just reported
Rosie for targeted harassment may lead
to see if Twitter does indeed have a
double standard
everyone knows if Rosie were
conservative Twitter would suspend her
in a hot second so Twitter put your
money where your mouth is hashtag me -
Rosie replied simply open Shapiro's
response Rosie all victims deserve to be
believed and the story doesn't end there
joining us now an exclusive interview
bench bureau editor-in-chief of The
Daily wire now I know you just heard
from Twitter I want you to hold on to
that for one second just so we can make
sure everybody's up to speed
Oh original tweet which I saw fly by to
where she says two million dollars to
Senator Susan Collins Senator Jeff Flake
if they vote no no I will not kill
Americans that's what she tweeted I
don't know how this is killing Americans
that's okay for this sour rich I think
it was supposed to say super but she was
impaired in some way while doing this
probably with her fingers DME Susan DM
you Jeff you responded that if Trump
orders sessions to investigate Rosie he
will be carved into Rushmore by Friday
which I thought was a pretty good burn
but what inspired you to pile on this
vest because it was already out of
control well I mean it was obvious that
she had actually violated at least
formally 18 USC 202 10 to a 1/2 of
initials yeah exactly there's a specific
provision of the US Code and in doing so
she should have done this on Twitter and
so I sort of piled on a little bit and
she responded by essentially telling me
to perform an anatomical act on her that
certainly would fall under me to sexual
harassment so but but what was weird
about is that she told me to perform it
on a male appendage of hers was weird
because yeah it was
right now I think that's that's probably
smart and and so I responded by
essentially saying that she was already
a felon there was no need to make
herself into a homophobic sexual
harasser as well yeah absolutely the
serious part of this is that she told
you to do things to her that of course
Harvey Weinstein and lots of people are
in trouble for trying to get people to
do to them and if there was I think I
mean if a man said this to a woman you
say conservative versus liberal but if
any of the normal tables were turned
people would recoil in horror and just
would really be on your side but not
this time
no question I mean if I had said exactly
the same words to to Rosie O'Donnell
that she said to me on Twitter I've very
little doubt that I would have been
suspended or expelled from Twitter for
targeted harassment or abuse under under
their rules so I decided to find out
exactly how Twitter operated and so I
reported her for targeted harassment and
abuse and then I have now received back
their notice that apparently there was
no violation of the Twitter rules which
is astonishing they say that she did not
actually perform behavior that crosses
the line into abuse which minoo it's I
totally understand why we can't read
these tweets on there because they're
really obscene and abusive but that's
why Twitter probably should have done
something if they cared about enforcing
their own rules I actually don't want
Rosie O'Donnell tossed off Twitter I
find her far too amusing and I'm sad
that she blocked me today but that said
I think the Twitter should be held to
account for its own enforcement of the
rules because it's wildly inconsistent
yeah look we're looking right there
where you can see that that Rosie
blocked you
it does seem very hypocritical on
Twitter's part which is sort of the
focus because rosie has gone off a bunch
of times before I mean she has a long
Twitter history some of her best times
were during the debates where she called
President Trump all kinds of names
comparing him to body parts saying how
orange he was talking about his
appearance I mean again things that if
tweeted at a woman you know there were
tweeted at Hillary Clinton about her
appearance people would be all up in
arms but this is what she was doing to
Donald Trump she even said he was like
the snake oil salesman from Little House
on the Prairie which I kind of liked for
obvious reasons but
all these things going on she's on
Twitter but Twitter does nothing about
it when she attacks someone with what
should be sexual harassment they have a
track record of banning other people for
saying things like this though well I
mean they do have a track record of at
least blocking people's tweets for that
are considered abusive or suspending
people who are abusive they have a track
record of going after people for
political reasons as well again their
Terms of Service
suggest that you are not allowed to
issue tweets like this but they've
rather arbitrary standard obviously for
what they choose to enforce or not
enforce my guess that they didn't want
to open the can of worms that would have
necessitated opening in order to take
any action against Rosie O'Donnell for
suggesting that I do certain things to
her which yeah is horrifying I'm stuck
on the fact that she seemed very sincere
in the fact when she went on originally
and she tweeted long tweets about
exactly how much money she wanted to
give for them to vote no and DM me and I
mean she sounded very serious so I don't
know yes there's a lot of debate right
now about whether or not that's a
violation of the law since it was on
Twitter we'll see ben shapiro hat tip to
you my friend thank you for coming on